Now tell me where is your master
where is grand admiral thrawn
I will start my operations here and
pull the rebels apart piece by piece
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new mandalorian season 2 video for ahsoka
tano versus grand admiral thrawn as they teased
during episode 5. so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
they tease this huge fight in the future between
ahsoka and thrawn they also included some clever
visual easter eggs for thrawn in other places
during the episode you may have spotted so we'll
break it all down and explain what it means for
the future of the mandalorian series and the
potential ahsoka tano spin-off series that's
been rumored all year and over a long time
fans have always wanted them to do an heir
to the empire thrawn style trilogy in the movies
it looks like they might actually be bringing that
into the live-action disney plus series though
but careful for spoilers for everything that
happened during episode 5 and on the mandalorian
so far if you haven't seen any of the episodes
just starting at the beginning here number 10
ahsoka tano said that during the episode she
was after information that the magistrate named
morgan ellsbeth had a lot of you also may have
noticed too that she's bruce lee's goddaughter
in a stunt person in real life so that's how they
were able to do such a cool fight scene with that
mandalorian bheskar spear but it was until that
final scene after the big fight that we actually
learned that it's the location of grand admiral
thrawn in the seventh fleet that ahsoka is after
yes i also think that this has something to do
with the whereabouts of ezra bridger because the
last time we saw all these characters ahsoka tano
ezra bridger and thrawn was during the star wars
rebels finale so i will talk more about ezra later
in this video too since it seems like most of the
major animated characters that dave filoni either
created or helped bring back into the canon are
coming to the live-action mandalorian series and
other disney plus series in the future number nine
grand admiral thrawn is probably one of the few
major fan favorite characters who are big
enough to be a galactic level threat on par
with emperor palpatine or darth vader just
to make comparisons to the star wars movies
so it feels like dave filoni and jon favreau
are going to use him as part of their end game
for the mandalorian series make all the avengers
and game jokes you want we're in the end game now
and it also seems like they're setting up a new
cinematic universe with these live-action disney
plus series that'll be interconnected like a
potential ahsoka spin-off series that covers a lot
of what's happening with grand admiral thrawn it's
sort of like them doing what the mcu is doing with
their disney plus marvel series and all the big
marvel phase 4 and marvel phase 5 movies but just
in the star wars universe like i said wouldn't
it be amazing if they did an heir to the empire
style thrawn trilogy but now it seems like they're
doing it in the disney plus series so to speak to
slowly introducing bits of legends canon back into
the official canon but number eight even before
ahsoka mentions thrawn's name some of you may have
spotted some of the visual easter eggs referencing
him in the background during the episode so if you
zoom in enhance on the hk87 assassin droids yes
i know big knights of the old republic easter egg
for hk47 you look at their heads and they actually
bear the insignia of thrawn's seventh fleet morgan
ellsbeth has supposedly been working for thrawn
helping plunder worlds to gain the resources to
build the empire's starfleet ever since revenge of
the sith so it makes sense that all of her weapons
and her gear comes from thrawn's seventh fleet
number seven how is grand admiral thrawn connected
to moff gideon and what's going on in the galaxy
during the events of the mandalorian series
because this is the first we're actually hearing
of him there was actually something interesting
though that giancarlo esposito said in an
interview after the mandalorian season 2 episode
4. that was the episode where we finally saw him
off gideon for the first time during season
2 and we got the reveal of his experiments in
cloning more answers about what he's doing with
midichlorians and grogu's blood using that to
create his new dark troopers also big dark forces
video game easter egg but during his interview he
talks about higher powers during the galaxy
so i'm going to screen cap this and just read
what he says he says when the people flow out of
control and there are all these different Moffs
who've been assigned to different areas to be
wardens of isn't there one person or someone that
may have guidance over all of them then he said
that they'll answer all those questions during
season two he talks about the dark troopers like
their super soldiers using them to sort of instill
order around the galaxy so we're just hyping up
them rolling them out later this year then he
raises another really interesting question saying
also why does moff gideon know everything what's
going on everywhere he has some kind of incredible
intelligence source so number six given all this
information in big reveals during episode five
and so far on the mandalorian clearly i think the
incredible source of information that giancarlo
esposito is talking about and this mysterious
person who has guidance over all the Moffs is
grand admiral thrawn technically a moff is a
civilian governor of a sector of space controlling
many systems and a grand admiral is a military
commander of an entire fleet of the empire
the seventh fleet is thrawn's fleet the only
reason right now that thrawn would technically
outrank moff gideon if they're adhering to the
rules of the empire long live the empire as he
said earlier which they're trying to bring back
is because moff gideon isn't a grand moff and
even if he were a grand moff he and thrawn would
be more like equals in terms of authority within
the empire the way things were set up originally
but if you haven't read a lot of the thrawn canon
before or seen any of the rebels the way he's sort
of pitched within the star wars universe is that
he's the best most intelligent military commander
that the galaxy has ever seen the way he's
expressed especially during star wars rebels was
as a very sherlockian villain like a moriarty to a
sherlock and for those of you that didn't actually
watch the rebels series he was actually voiced
by lars mikkelson he's mads mikkelson's brother
but he also played a villain during sherlock
season 3 with benedict cumberbatch i know everyone
would love to see benedict cumberbatch play live
action thrawn but they could actually just paint
lars mikkelson blue if they're having everyone
play the animated versions of their characters
in live action ahsoka tano is kind of the
exception to that so far because rosario
dawson is playing the live-action version of her
and ashley eckstein did the animated version but
you have katee sakhoff playing animated bogatan
then playing live action Bo Katan so the president
is there for lars mikkelson to come and play
live-action thrawn on the mandalorian series
number five originally it was actually darth
vader anakin skywalker himself that brought thrawn
into the empire but it was still when he was
anakin skywalker before he became darth vader
during the clone wars thrawn had actually grown
up as a member of the chis ascendancy royal navy
over here in this part of the unknown regions that
his race controls it's a pretty big area of space
even though it looks kind of small on the map here
after learning about palpatine and witnessing the
fall of the republic after order 66 he sort of
decided that in the big regime change the best way
to help his people the chiss survive in this new
political regime was from the inside so we went
to the emperor and offered his racist knowledge of
the unknown regions which the emperor desperately
wanted but because thrawn was so much better than
all the other military commanders he quickly rose
to the rank of grand admiral so because he was
such a badass a lot of you were confused why it
seemed like he was beaten so easily by the rebels
in the rebels finale well there are some theories
about that so number four if you didn't read all
the thrawn stories he actually found out that the
emperor was planning on killing him after he took
care of the rebels in his final mission assuming
that he was going to take the rebel fleet apart
piece by piece as he said during rebels so there
are some theories that he lost that battle during
the rebels finale on purpose with the intent to
dip out of the galaxy for a little while into
the unknown regions regardless of the outcome
of the battle to sit out the events of the
original trilogy of movies until he could
gather more resources and develop a plan to either
outfox emperor palpatine or to get him to chill
on that kill order regardless in the rebels finale
the last we saw of him and ezra bridger were that
ezra's space whales which had the ability to
navigate hyperspace naturally took thrawn's
seventh fleet deep into the unknown regions where
they couldn't threaten the rebellion anymore
all right before the events of star wars a new
hope all we know now is that at some point ahsoka
came back after looking for ezra in the unknown
regions with sabine wren and probably around the
same time thrawn found his way back to the outer
rim territories which is based on the way they're
hyping him up it seems more likely that thrawn
found his way back before the events of return
of the jedi the battle of endor the battle of
jakku and just decided to wait in the outer rim
hidden so that the emperor and the remainder of
the old empire could die off which he was not a
big fan of and he could then swoop in and recreate
a new empire as he saw fit one that would benefit
his people the chiss much more than the previous
regime remember thrawn is not loyal to the emperor
or the empire he's loyal first to his people the
chiss so everything he does is for their benefit
ultimately even though he seems like he's this
big villain inside the empire had the emperor
wound up killing thrawn as he planned his people
the chiss would have suffered the same fate as
the mandalorians did eventually like thinking
about the great mandalorian purge in moff gideon
so number three connections demof gideon we know
he came up in the imperial security bureau before
he was a Moff they're the branch of the empire
that's tasked with information gathering and
secret keeping so maf gideon would have had access
to all of palpatine's secrets and resources hidden
all over the galaxy now we don't know whether
or not thrawn played a role in the original
mandalorian purge mostly it seems like that's
a Moff gideon thing because every time bokutan
talks about the purge and taking back the planet
mandalore in the darksaber she keeps talking about
moff gideon and it also kind of seems like that
happened during the events of the original trilogy
so it's more likely that emperor palpatine is
behind the mandalorian purge when he was still
around regardless though in this new mandalorian
series in this part of the timeline moff gideon is
more like the darth vader to thrawn's emperor
so once they do come around to the new battle
for mandalore whatever the final season of the
mandalorian series winds up being that's sort
of the end game for the show is them retaking
the planet mandalore grand admiral thrawn will
be a big part of that whether or not he played
a role in their original downfall in the purge
so number two my early prediction is is that
we'll get another thrawn teaser in the mandalorian
season two finale either we'll just see a shot of
the seventh fleet with his star destroyer chimera
and maybe maybe small chance they've already cast
an actor for a short cameo scene and will actually
see him show up on screen for a few seconds in
the finale and then he'll just show up more on the
potential ahsoka spin-off series because i really
do feel like episode 5 was meant to be a backdoor
pilot for the ahsoka series it's really cool as
a fan service episode and pushing the mandalorian
series plot four but there's just so many things
that they set up it feels like a lot of that's
going to be addressed on a separate tv show in
number one as for ezra bridger there have been all
kinds of actors teasing fans with live action ezra
all year but that being said because you can't do
one without the other thrawn can't come back and
ahsoka can't come back after rebels without ezra
also coming back i think they'll introduce the
new live-action ezra either on the mandalorian
series along with sabine wren or at least on the
ahsoka series and the mandalorian series is all
about mandalorians it's right there in the title
and sabine wren is a mandalorian by birth from
house wren and she's the one who gave Bo Katan
the dark saber in the first place so of course
they have to introduce her to the live action
at some point but i also think the ezra bridger
character will be connected to the jedi that
ahsoka tano spoke of when she was telling mando
to take grogu to the jedi temple on taithon i will
do a separate video about that about all the jedi
and sith characters from canon and from legends
that they might bring back through that storyline
but post all your theories in the comments
below do you think that maf gideon has been
working for grand admiral thrawn this whole time
and when do you think we'll actually see thrawn
on screen for the first time congratulations
juan battista you're the giveaway winner for
my last big star wars video please email me
on the about page of my channel so i can get
your contact details everyone click here for my
full mandalorian season 2 episode 5 ahsoka video
and click here to learn about grogu's full
backstory in jedi history and how he fits
into the star wars movies thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe this is the way!